rebecca what is up uh so my husband and
i
are really at a crossroads with my
in-laws
and family my niece
uh who's a very young minor recently
gave birth
to a baby with her boyfriend who's also
a minor
how young minor um 15.
okay yes it's
a very complicated and tough situation
right now the mother my niece is trying
to decide what to do with the child
um what is that okay go ahead go ahead
sorry probably another call yeah the
crossroads is that
there are a couple options on the table
and
a few of them are
very tough
maybe possibly even unsafe options for
the baby
and my husband and i don't know how
involved
to get uh to fight for
you know the best situation for the
child
um so if there is less than optimal
situations
or things that you wouldn't do
that's one thing if there's ever in any
circumstance in any neighborhood in any
home in any
family system a situation where a kid is
not safe
then my expectation is that every adult
in the neighborhood in the family
walking down the street every stranger
goes into that situation kicking and
screaming on behalf of that child
that's my that's my two cents on that so
give me an example of what you feel is
uncomfortable or a little bit weird
you're being kind of vague
so walk me through a couple of
situations here
okay um so the first option
is that my sister-in-law um has offered
to adopt the baby
she still is at home um
with her parents and a couple other of
her
siblings that are in their mid to late
30s one of them
struggles with substance abuse and
is really really deep in that it's been
many many years
and is not someone that i would
consider safe around children or babies
especially
he's known to be violent with animals
never been
um abusive towards a kid that we know of
but has also never lived with one
sure um so that's situation number one
okay so they so they're gonna be they're
going to be and i wanna i wanna parse
that out real quick
she might get adopted by her sister
right
um sister-in-law or her
boyfriend's sister right
no so it's my niece's aunt my
sister-in-law
okay okay your sister-in-law okay so she
might get adopted there
into a house where there's a bunch of
adults living there which
wouldn't be how you would draw it up but
isn't necessarily a bad thing there's
lots of families that have lots of
interesting
intergenerational dynamics and people
coming and going and that may not be how
i draw it up but i'm not always have a
problem with that
particularly there's lots of different
ways that culturally that families live
together and that's
beautiful and it's okay for how they
choose to do it it's not how i do it but
how they do how they do it
but then you added another thing which
is there's somebody there
that's an addict that's got violence
history towards animals
he's not a safe guy and you are worried
about a baby being put in that
environment okay so that's number one
what's the second one
yep um the second one is that
at this young age um
they're encouraging her to
go out on her own and raise the child
um which
is scary for us because um i mean
her and her boyfriend they they
are both very young and they both come
from broken homes
and haven't had a great example of
what it should look like to raise a
child um i mean that's like that's a
that's a really tough road to hoe for a
15 year old girl by herself
out on her own are you all in a position
to take her in
what's your what's your solution to that
challenge
um well so we live very far away
we have offered to adopt the baby
um we would not um
at this time be interested in taking
them in as a
a unit all three of them the boyfriend
the mother and the baby um
but that is i mean that's
as far as we've sort of been able to
come up with there's there doesn't
really seem to be i mean it's such a
emotionally like intense situation
what do people say when you when you
offered to you and your husband
offered to adopt the baby what was the
response
well so it was communicated to my
in-laws not to the mother directly
because it's only been a couple days
since birth she's still recovering
from a slightly traumatic birth but
um response good from one
um maybe not so much from the other
because they don't want the baby to be
far away
sure so i fully support
you adopting the baby if that's what
y'all want to do
i fully support you guys having her and
the baby move in
because then at that point you're
basically adopting a teenager and
um that little baby so you're becoming a
grandma all right instead of a um
adoptive mother i fully support you not
having all three of them move in
i don't want two teenagers who are not
married living in my house
raising a kid because then you've got
children raising a child and it's going
to get messy messy messy and messy
and family members of his side are going
to come out of the woodwork
right and when they start to find out
about this baby and it's just going to
be
a mess as far as you know of that baby
possibly going to live in a situation
where there's an addict
and there's safety concerns there's
violence in that home there's adults
coming and going particularly drug
trafficking coming and going
dude i'm going to go bang and yell and
be loud
with one caveat if you and your husband
have had a hard conversation
about do we want to expand our family
and this is gonna be that baby
then you are have emotionally invested
in that baby
and the temptation is to start looking
at every other situation is less than
what you would do
and less than what you would give and
there comes a moment when you start
imposing your values and your judgments
on
everything else because quote unquote
that's my baby now
and anything less than that may be
coming to your house is
a loss for you guys right and so if you
all have gone through that hard
conversation
less about we're going to rescue that
baby and more we're going to expand our
family and those are two
totally separate conversations um
because one you rescue the baby then you
figure out what to do later like i'm
getting that baby out of a burning
building right now and then we're going
to figure it out
the other is no i'm committing to the
next
for the rest of my life i'm the baby's
mother
i'm going to adopt her and raise her as
my own and in conjunction with her 15
year old mother
you are making a decision to have a
complex
enriched beautiful challenging life
which is honorable and noble and
extraordinary
but you have to temper that with other
situations that might have to happen to
that baby
right and so there's a difference
between having an uncle that smokes weed
and there's
that's not it's against the law and dumb
i don't like that around my kid
and then there's a difference between
someone's violent and they are an addict
and they are bringing hard drugs into
this house and they are does that make
sense you know what i mean
so it's temp just tempering your heart
and your plan for moving forward
and so i am a thousand percent on board
if the baby's gonna go to an unsafe
situation
go for it if the baby is
um if you all want to adopt this child
you'll have to go and be very very vocal
and be very direct
and probably get in a car and tell
people that you're coming and you want
to have a hard conversation about this
baby
and meet with the 15 year old and the 15
year old's mother
and the 15 year old's father if he's
still in the picture and
because this is still a minor right and
at the end of the day
sometimes you got to let the beginning
part of this play out knowing that we're
going to pick this baby up in foster
care because they're gonna try a
scenario
one or scenario two and it's not gonna
work and the baby's gonna be welcome to
come live with us
um and it's a hard messy family
situation but don't hesitate
ever if you think that that baby is not
safe
is not um going to be okay
that you don't reach out to the
authorities right away get super
involved get other people who know what
they're doing super involved
right away but it's noble that you want
to be a part of this
this baby's life a 15 year old is still
a child
a 15 year old is still a child
and they need to be honored like a child
even though they're now thrust into
adulthood
so have a hard conversation with your
husband and go make your move um
i appreciate you rebecca that's hard
it's really hard and i appreciate you
guys wanting to be
involved in it make sure you temper your
desire for this baby
the desire to rescue this kid and to
raise this kid with it
he may or she may end up in other
situations they're going to look
different but may not be terrible
but if they are terrible call the
calvary